(bouncy jazz tune)
- [Voiceover] Millions of
people around the world
enjoy a hot cup of Joe every day.
But why do we all love
this weird, bitter taste?
In theory, humans should not
enjoy the taste of coffee,
because we're born with a natural reflex
to reject bitterness.
We think this is because
bitterness is generally
an indication of poison.
So if coffee reminds us of poison,
why do we drink it?
One theory is that people
consume bitter foods
when it provides some kind
of pharmacological benefit,
and one benefit, it wakes us up
with a good dose of caffeine.
Caffeine is a powerful drug
that not only gives you
that jolt of energy, but it's
also been linked to improving
overall cognitive function.
When the positive feeling we
receive from drinking coffee
outweighs the rejection of the bitterness,
our bodies seem to be more
willing to accept the flavor.
But this isn't true of everyone.
Research has found that some
people may taste the chemicals
that produce a bitter flavor
more intensely than others.
People whose receptors are
less active than others
may have a better chance of
accepting the taste of coffee.
So, if you enjoy coffee,
you're working against nature
telling you, "You shouldn't."
But that kind of makes you want it more,
now doesn't it?
(bouncy jazz music)
(creaking)